jetzt müsst ihr starke nerven haben
gleich seht ihr die ersten bilder von
aliens die sich auf wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse stützen und ich muss sagen
schön sind sie nicht allein zumindest
gewöhnungsbedürftig ein forschungsteam
aus oxford hat einen komplett neuen
ansatz genutzt um endlich herauszufinden
wie unsere außerirdischen nachbarn
aussehen könnten und ihr ergebnis ist
verblüffend wie das forschungsteam auf
dieses ergebnis gekommen ist um wie
konkret wir uns also unsere
außerirdischen nachbarn vorstellen
müssen jetzt sind klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja heute aus duisburg das ist sie gibt
das ist bei den meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern umstritten doch wo
genau sie stecken und wie sie aussehen
die außerirdischen das wissen wir nicht
seit vielen jahrzehnten suchen
forschungsteams weltweit nach ihnen wir
analysieren planetensysteme horchen ins
alle und untersuchen monde indizien für
ihre existenz gibt es noch und nöcher
es fehlt nur noch der eindeutige beweis
und so stellt auch das forschungsteam
aus oxford gleich am anfang der
wissenschaftlichen abhandlung namens
darwins aliens erst einmal klar etwas
über das aussehen oder das verhalten von
aliens zu erforschen
das sei wahrhaftig nicht einfach doch
dann geht es auch schon ans eingemachte
konkret geht es an die evolutionstheorie
charles darwin viele von euch haben ein
bisschen davon ja in der schule mit
bekommt doch dass sie auch genutzt
werden kann um medien vorhersagen zu
machen
darauf ist bisher noch niemand gekommen
bislang die man eher von modellen aus
die man hier auf der erde in
fachbereichen wie biologie physik und
chemie beobachten kann
um das dann zu übertragen und so
rückschlüsse auf das aussehen und das
verhalten von aliens zu bekommen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von der universität oxford gehen jetzt
tatsächlich zum ersten mal von der
evolutionstheorie des guten alten
charles darwins aus ihre these genau wie
das leben auf unserer erde sind auch
außerirdische der natürlichen selektion
ausgesetzt heißt also konkret nur die
lebewesen die am stärksten und fittesten
sind überleben so müssen sich also auf
fremde lebensformen auf fremden planeten
immer wieder weiterentwickeln um zu
überleben weiter gehen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
davon aus dass auch in der heimat von
außerirdischen große veränderungen
stattgefunden haben bzw stattfinden die
dann wiederum große evolutionäre
schritte zur folge haben ebenso wie bei
der entwicklung des lebens auf der erde
mit großen veränderungen sind solche
entwicklung gemeint die immer komplexere
und höhere lebensformen hervorbringen
beispielsweise die entwicklung zu einem
mehrzelligen organismus nur die die am
besten an ihre umwelt angepasst sind
überleben und das könnte zb so aussehen
ein riesiger wurm der otto mied er
existiert unter der planetenoberfläche
und besteht aus verschiedenen wesen die
voneinander abhängig sind und
miteinander
parieren wie sehe da eine erste
begegnung aus oder solche wesen am ende
so das fazit des forschungsteams könnte
ein außerirdisches wesen entstanden sein
dass uns menschen sehr ähnlich ist sam
levin einer der beteiligten forscher
formuliert das so vorausgesetzt dass
aliens großen veränderungen ausgesetzt
sind was dem entsprechen würde wie sich
komplexität in den arten auf der erde
aus gebildet hat können wir sagen dass
eine gewisse berechenbarkeit der
evolution dazu führen würde dass sie
aussehen wie wir und das forschungsteam
ist von seinem ergebnis überzeugt ihre
theoretischen voraussagen zum menschen
den alien gelten auch für diejenigen
unter den aliens die beispielsweise
stickstoff atmen oder keine dna besitzen
das alles klingt ganz logisch denn warum
sollten lebensformen im all nicht
ähnliche lösungen für ihre probleme
gefunden haben wie wir natürlich jeweils
angepasst an ihre umweltbedingungen in
einer umwelt mit viel licht wäre es ja
durchaus sinnvoll so etwas wie ein auge
zu entwickeln um es jedoch zwei oder
sechs sind so konkret werden die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus oxford nicht das sagen sie auch
selbst so sam levin wir können immer
noch nicht sagen ob williams auf zwei
beinen laufen oder große grüne augen
haben werden andere astrobiologen sehen
das etwas anders
manche von ihnen sind überzeugt davon
dass die meisten der extraterrestrischen
lebewesen ihre existenz schon längst
geupdatet haben auf eine künstliche
intelligenz die uns weit überlegen ist
das ist eine extrem spannende abnahme
dazu sollte ich mal ein video machen und
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier an abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter wenn ihr drauf
klickt mit haben die aliens zu uns
gelockt vielleicht sind sie also schon
da ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran